have you ever asked somebody
why they use an iphone so we're gonna
start with dom which smartphone is in
your pocket right now do i reveal it
right now or got the iphone 10. oh there
it is there it is sometimes it's hard to
break away from that ecosystem what is
it about this ecosystem you're talking
about judner you're next man the
pressure's on iphone 10. wow it's just
two phones so far i'm gonna be straight
up it's imessage man in the ecosystem
whoa
that's what it is for me so to be fair
you need to be totally into the apple
ecosystem so i'm talking apple music
iphones max the whole thing but on the
flip side if you're in the apple
ecosystem and the tech outweighs
everything else i would pick these up
the ecosystem
the the ecosystem there are tales all
over the internet about this ecosystem
in tech reviews and all kinds of iphone
videos probably every homepod video on
the internet has that word or that
phrase in it somewhere and even in
regular everyday conversations if you
ask somebody why they use an iphone it
more or less comes down to the same
answer sometimes it is just because it's
the best all-around phone and they
believe the hardware is superior
that's sometimes but really often like
really really often the answer has
something to do with the ecosystem
ecosystem a biological community of
interacting organisms and their physical
environment so in tech you know an
ecosystem is just a community of
interacting objects so apple makes a ton
of devices you know the iphone the ipad
the mac
the apple watch the apple tv
the homepod airpods but they also make a
lot of software and proprietary
technology that ties them all together
airplay
airdrop
continuity icloud so once they can draw
you into the ecosystem somewhere with
one of their devices let's say an iphone
for example you get an iphone like many
people do then they can try to lure you
to spend more money on other apple
products because they just work so well
together now most companies have a
family of products that's not new it's
not like apple's the only one doing that
but what makes this particularly unique
ecosystem so successful maybe the most
successful ecosystem ever
is not only how well they work together
but the walls they've built up around
those things living inside this apple
ecosystem is sort of like what we call
a walled garden you may have heard that
expression before meaning everything
that's in the garden in these walls is
this beautiful luscious garden
everything is green it's everything you
could ever want
but these walls on the outside are
really tall
and they kind of don't want you trying
to climb out or trying to explore beyond
those walls just look at all the great
stuff in here basically once you get a
couple of apple devices you start to get
into the ecosystem let's say you get an
iphone and a macbook just those two
things they make it as easy as possible
you start using imessage you start
getting text messages on your phone and
then you can reply to them on your
computer super easy blue bubbles
everywhere your web browsing on your
phone then you sit down on your computer
and it shows up for you to pick up
exactly where you left off you have
icloud drive so any files on one are
always on the other anything not showing
up airdrop peer to peer sharing
legendary you have tethering so the
macbook always has the iphone's internet
wherever you go want to make a video
call i mean i guess facetime's right
there you can answer it on either device
you ask siri to remind you for something
it'll put it in the reminders app every
time so okay now you're in the market
for a smart watch
well i mean
just you just get an apple watch like
what other options are there really now
you can answer text on your watch too
blue bubbles everywhere answer calls on
your watch there's facetime still ask
siri to set reminders on the watch it'll
put them in the reminders app everything
works together so beautifully okay now
you're in the market for a smart speaker
it's a pretty new market a couple of
options out there
seems like it makes perfect sense to
just go with the apple one now suddenly
wireless headphones are gaining steam
you're in the market for some wireless
earbuds air pods are right there they
work perfectly you get the idea all
these services and products are designed
to be as good as possible yes of course
but they're also designed to be these
little hooks to keep you in the apple
ecosystem to keep you giving them
information and to keep you buying more
apple products as long as possible and
the way to keep you using those products
is to make those products as good as
possible within the ecosystem and those
are keywords within the ecosystem this
explains the existence of so many apple
products that on the surface or from the
outside from behind those walls can seem
kind of limited or pointless or dumb
especially in new markets where there's
just the beginnings of competition like
why does the homepod exist in 2018 a
smart speaker that only uses siri only
uses apple music does not connect to
bluetooth does not connect to anything
that's not an iphone does not have a
headphone jack
because for that guy who uses apple
music and has an icloud account and has
an iphone it's kind of perfect to be
honest though i've even been guilty of
being in the ecosystem you know despite
being i mean i use android so i'm not
tied in as deep i use some
multi-platform stuff spotify dropbox
things like that
but
i'm a final cut pro editor
because final cut pro is really good and
final cut pro is mac only and it will
probably pretty much always be mac only
so what about leaving what about getting
out of the ecosystem well in apple's
case pretty much everything is tied to
your icloud account and if you want to
get out of the ecosystem you have to rip
that information out of your icloud and
sort of import it into that new service
a lot of times much easier said than
done the more closely tied to icloud
that device is the more hooks it has
into other parts of the ecosystem that
make it harder to take out so
accessories like airpods for example you
know they work perfectly with things
like your iphone and your ipad and your
macbook because of the w1 chip they pair
effortlessly we all know it just kind of
works the apple way but if you want to
switch to another pair of headphones
it's just that one hook in and you can
move to another pair of wireless
headphones and get away with it now if
you use apple music and want to switch
to spotify because it's clearly better
again it's like one hook but good luck
trying to switch your entire library
between the platforms entire companies
have been born trying to make that
process easier but trying to leave the
iphone
to go to another phone that's not in the
ecosystem is tough because there's a lot
of hooks into this all of your app
purchases are gone your face time is
gone your airpods become useless your
home pod becomes useless you can't use
the reminders app anymore your apple
watch becomes a paperweight and imessage
is gone and then the iphone the holy
grail for shepherding people into this
garden is so hard to leave that a new
phone could come along with a better
screen
better battery no notch a better camera
better battery life
a headphone jack
and they'd still skip it because
that ecosystem though it's kind of
incredible also by the way there's other
ecosystems too there's google's amazons
samsung's there's there's some more
complete than others and just generally
you notice ecosystems from everyone are
expanding and evolving two years ago you
didn't really need smart appliances in
your ecosystem as a tech company a
couple days ago amazon bought ring for a
billion dollars to get ahead on smart
video doorbells that's just kind of what
we're living in with all these companies
building up their ecosystems some with
little walls some with huge walls some
are just as open as possible google's
for example is probably the most
multi-platform possible you want google
photos you can get it anywhere you want
gmail you can get it anywhere things
like that are fun to see but it's still
interesting to look at and evaluate
apples which has been closed off for so
long the walls have been built for so
long that it kind of makes its own weird
case study
other than that that's pretty much it my
only suggestion would be
don't isolate yourself to just one
ecosystem don't lock yourself in or if
you are already locked in maybe take a
peek over those walls before it's too
late
thanks for watching
talk to you in the next one
peace